avec nous ce soir le PDG de produits
forestiers résolus Rémi Lalande bonsoir
Monsieur Lalande bonsoir
quel est l'état de la situation chez
résolu mais l'état de la situation est
que nous avons évacué la forêt depuis à
peu près une semaine donc tous les
opérations en forêt ont été suspendus
donc à même nos séries nous sommes à
épuiser le stock de bois rond qui existe
dans certains endroits on va avoir
épuisé les stocks disponibles on va
devoir malheureusement fermer quatre
séries dans les dans les heures à venir
et puis si la situation se perdure on va
probablement subir des impacts plus loin
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement
notamment au niveau des opérations de
portes des papiers lesquelles séries
vont fermer là on parle de les séries en
Abitibi donc courtois et Center qui sont
déjà fermés et puis au lac Saint-Jean à
gérardville et la doré en plus de
Baie-Comeau en plus de b-c quelle part
de vos activités sont à la
représentement toutes les opérations
forestières sont suspendues au niveau de
à compter de demain on parle de
peut-être le tiers de nos séries en
province vont être en arrêt d'opération
donc les travailleurs ne peuvent pas
travailler certains ont du même évacuer
exactement l'endroit où ils vivaient
qu'est-ce que vous proposez à ces
travailleurs-là dans ces circonstances
mais ce que je vous dirais c'est que
certains de nos travailleurs notamment
ceux qui travaillent en forêt qui ont
été réquises rééditionnés par la soif
pour aider avec l'effort de guerre donc
ils vont aider dans les efforts de
couper des faire des coupes feux entre
autres pour les autres malheureusement
quand on suspend les opérations il y en
a certains qui vont prendre des vacances
et pour d'autres ça veut dire
malheureusement un congé un congé forcé
un congé forcé donc une sorte de mise à
pied très temporaire on espère par
exemple la Baie-Comeau on annonce la
pluie dans les prochains quelques jours
on espère pouvoir regagner l'accès à la
forêt d'ici à la fin de semaine pour
pouvoir reprendre les opérations très
très rapidement donc ces travailleurs-là
doivent demander du chômage dans les
circonstances et on fait tout ce qu'on
peut pour vous aider notamment à remplir
les documents dans cette situation comme
celle-là vous avez donc il y a des
tranchées autour des installations
est-ce qu'il y a des installations qui
sont à risque mais ce que je vous dirais
c'est que les efforts qu'on déploie sont
pour appuyer la Sauveur et d'abord et
avant tout c'est pour protéger les
communautés pas nécessairement les
actifs de nos séries et ensuite c'est
les infrastructures importantes par
exemple les lignes de transmission
d'Hydro-Québec c'est les deux priorités
et nous quand la subsfure nous appelle
on réquisitionne les employés et les
aide pour protéger la communauté les
États les impacts pour l'industrie quand
on pense justement à l'étendue des feux
ça a fait que la valeur du bois sur pied
il y en a beaucoup qui va passer au
front on parlait de 800000 hectares
tantôt dans une année normale la récolte
s'étend à peu près 250 000 hectares ton
impact et significatif il y a aussi des
entrepreneurs forestiers qui ont dû
quitter les lieux très rapidement leurs
équipements vont malheureusement être
endommagés il y a plusieurs impacts
ricochets donc est-ce que vous êtes déjà
capable de mes les pertes économiques
pas encore pas encore ça va dépendre de
l'étendue quand ça arrête et comment
loin ça va mais ce qu'on voit en ce
moment c'est suspension d'activité on
est déjà en mode préparation pour la
suite des choses ce que les gens savent
peut-être pas c'est que nous on va
prendre accès aux secteur affectés pour
essayer d'aller récolter la fibre même
si endommagé il y a une certaine valeur
qui va brûlée vous allez récolter le
bois brûlé vous avez la responsabilité
de le récolter ce lundi nous avons la
responsabilité de le faire à l'intérieur
il y a quand même de la valeur à aller
chercher c'est plus difficile il y a une
réduction de la valeur du bois c'est un
travail quand même assez mais on
doit aller le faire et on va le faire
pour le mettre dans nos CV est-ce que
les pertes économiques cela dit
j'insiste un peu ce compte en millions
ou en dizaines de millions est-ce que
vous êtes capable de nous donner un
ordre de grandeur ben est-ce que je vous
dirais c'est que c'est sûr que ça va
être dans l'ordre de millions je pense
que c'est le facteur temps qui va
déterminer comment loin ça peut que ça
peut aller est-ce que ça affecte
directement beaucoup de vos partenaires
qui ont besoin de copeaux de patates
pour la pâte à papier pour le bois
d'oeuvre il y a aucun doute on parle
déjà d'une situation où il y a une
rareté de copeaux au Québec donc les
inventaires de copeaux en province sont
assez bas fait quand on suspend les
opérations forestières comme celle-là
pour une période prolongée ça va causer
encore plus de pression nous l'avons vu
dans les six derniers mois une
augmentation des prix de copeaux dû à la
rareté donc c'est un des impacts va
augmenter on présume va avoir une
pression généralisée sur le prix du bois
dans les deux trois derniers jours on a
vu quand même un regain au niveau des
prix et des volumes mais c'est un impact
quand il y a des phénomènes naturels
comme ça on le voit souvent que ce soit
tornade ouragan on peut voir des impacts
dans les prix on va voir comment
l'impact à long terme ça va être à
déterminer mais sur le coup c'est un
marché très liquide qui répond très
rapidement le bois d'oeuvre donc on le
voit dans les quelques derniers jours le
professeur Christian Messier professeur
en AM engagement forestier nous disait
cette semaine sur ce plateau que la
récolte de bois brûlées ni très facile
ni très rentable d'abord et avant tout
vous êtes d'accord avec ça et que résolu
donc à des obligations face à ce qui
reste comme matière une fois que le feu
est passé l'autre aspect des choses qui
ne mentionnait c'est que en aménagement
Foresti faudrait s'intéresser à de
nouvelles espèces davantage de feuillus
par exemple pour limiter les feux
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça ce que
je vous dirais c'est que l'aménagement
forestier et reconnu comme étant une
stratégie importante pour améliorer la
résilience de nos forêts donc quand on
pratique l'aménagement forestier comme
on le fait ici au Québec ça aide aux
forêts à résister aux pestes au fur et
évidemment la dégradation naturelle donc
c'est un impact important au niveau
d'utiliser du bois de feuillus c'est pas
un bois qui se travaille bien pour
construire une maison il est très lourde
il est pas très flexible c'est pour ça
qu'on utilise le de fibres longues qui
est le plus pratique beaucoup plus
inflammable
évidence je vous dirais que la forêt qui
brûle c'est parce que ce qui est là
aujourd'hui c'est du conifère donc c'est
ce qui va ce qui va brûler mais je vous
pose la question dans le fond est-ce
qu'il faut repenser notre aménagement
forestier au Québec absolument oui pour
plusieurs raisons puis nous on a fait un
appel quand même il y a quelques mois et
qu'on continue à le faire pour créer
justement une table de concertation pour
penser à la façon qu'on peut aménager la
forêt pour le futur et harmoniser tous
les intérêts des gens qui s'en servent
pour plusieurs raisons que ce soit pour
protéger la biodiversité mais aussi
adresser la vitalité de l'industrie
forestière qui fait face à des pression
importante mais la vitalité de
l'industrie forestière passe aussi par
des forêts qui ne brûlent pas absolument
mais il faut comprendre par contre que
c'est le cycle naturel dans la forêt
boréale c'est c'est difficile à voir
parce que ça impacte les communautés et
puis nous on est solidaires avec eux
mais la forêt parallèle même vous brûler
parce que c'est la faute finalement qui
cause les feux c'est une question de
voir
c'est une mauvaise année pour des feux
je pense que c'est la pire à date dans
les 10 dernières années donc c'est un
processus naturel on sait quoi faire
mais il y a toujours quand même des
impacts monsieur Lalande merci d'avoir
été avec plaisir merci beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]